[Music]
you watch this on the news a lot of
coverage of what's been going on in
Chicago yeah it's crazy yeah public
demonstrations in Chicago have you seen
it this week being NATO summit was in
Chicago and there were riots in the
streets
yeah Chicago police were forced to
disperse the crowd with healthy food I
know if you saw that they chest
they had a salad shooter they ran for it
yeah yeah one vegetable loved in the
crowd were thing they threw him tofu
they thought it was mozzarella Oh big
news of course a lot of people talking
about this over the weekend the first
ever transgender beauty pageant
contestant lost the Miss Universe
pageant yeah she said I can't believe
after all of those operations I still
got the shaft
[Applause]
Wow I thought I'd like that joke but
that was insane the crowd released you
couldn't see it they released balloons
after that they built parade floats in
the crowd amazing
a new report just came out it suggests
that Christopher Columbus may have
secretly been Jewish it also suggests
that his three ships were actually named
the Nina the Pinta and the Seinfeld not
likely next month the new biography is
gonna come out about the life of
300-pound New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie yeah yeah the biography is
called are you gonna finish that
large man a penthouse a penthouse in New
York City has gone on sale for 90
million dollars 90 yet comes with up
four bedrooms three bathrooms and 80
million dollars in cash just in the
middle that makes now it makes sense to
me it does why would it all right Thank
You Ryan cash that big pile in the
living room now the creators of Angry
Birds will soon release a line of luxury
jewelry based on the characters in the
game yeah
after all what woman doesn't want to be
told honey I saw this string of dirty
pigs and thought of you
couldn't believe this story about an
Arby's in Michigan an Arby's served a
customer a sandwich with a piece of
human finger inside yeah the manager
apologized and gave the customers some
free hair in his shake that's what those
jokes were it's hard to get past the
premise of the joke everyone's just
thinking about the finger in the
sandwich and thinking how could you tell
[Music]
[Applause]
they're not are they a sponsor
it's our visa sponsor I'm being told RVs
is a sponsor
well Andy I'll tell you how you can tell
one's a human finger the other the
best-tasting sandwich you'll ever
[Applause]
[Music]
cleared that problem up oh boy we're
gonna comic book fans here settle down
fellas DC Comics is reporting that one
of their main characters will come out
soon as gay yeah not only that but the
Justice League will be comprised of a
cop a construction worker in an Indian
Channel yeah I can't even make the
into whatever y-m-c-a you got guys are
really attractive that a lot of the
mirror as a child sure listen you're
gonna like this this interesting story a
new survey just came out and it finds
that sex is better when you're on
vacation at least that's what my wife
emailed me from the Bahamas
[Applause]